hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to seven days to die
I'm here with Wade again as usual hello
Wade hey Mark are you doing how was that
long period of silence it was very quiet
and peaceful very quiet - the sounds of
death around us
the sounds of Moaning Myrtle over there
in the bathroom yeah Myrtle ha ha ha
Zuba morning morose you still dumb and
ugly anyway what was it i wasn't saying
ok anyway let me recap what happened
over the night we started the mine and
we're actually doing really well in the
mine we found a good bit of iron I have
19 iron ingots and 9 coal ore that is
not kohler that's supposed to be led
bars oh let him get there goes this is
bugged out for some reason and I got
some coal so I have lumps of coal we
have a lead ingots which is used for
bullets I have a so many more craftable
items that showed up in my list and we
are going to start a farm yeah I got a
little excited about that I'm actually
excited because we're actually gonna
make some progress I'll clean that up Oh
God let me shoot so I guess I'm you go
ahead and break out it's almost more it
is morning okay yeah that's true
do you've an axe I do indeed you do I'm
gonna make you or I'm gonna give you the
iron so that you can make you yourself
some tools the F sticks okay okay here's
the iron I'm dropping all of it on the
floor got it you got it good
alright I'm busting out air my
gangbusters we get out of here yeah
christopher walken yeah i don't know why
i don't know why these dummies gained a
house
these ow there's something on the wing
some thing out there hi
it's like a recap of our conversation at
dinner last night it really is yeah
totally except for last night if you
guys couldn't get that route of the yeah
we had dinner together cuz we live
together and we sleep in the same bed
Molly doesn't know she oh that's awkward
what we don't do anything baby we just
sleep in the same bed whether she
doesn't know about it
oh okay cuz she's there too yeah but she
doesn't know I sneak right in in between
the sheets and she never knows
in fact you didn't know until I just
told you right now did you I didn't know
you're so tiny
haha
hahaha in what way what do you mean by
that every way every way huh
well eh I had no idea that's the best
unspecific answer I can get thank you
thank you for that I'm digging up some
dirt where are we gonna put our farm
we're gonna put it on a high elevated
place right that's far the best idea um
how will we got a shovel you have a
shovel
yeah I've Istanbul I have a lot of them
I'm a I had just enough iron to make
every single tool that I needed so I
balled them that is how pro I am I here
some zambese damn bees oh there they are
Sami knife to the head that a song hit
me nice to the head and now you are dead
I think I'll go to bed and then it goes
down the night look I read keep rhyming
come on I'm good at this I stabbed him
in the head while Mark was in bed it's
something that they dread getting
stabbed in the head but I know you like
my beatboxing well that's the heck is
that
well my beatboxing you didn't like it uh
I decided like guys that's what it was
yeah some new revolutionary sound that
you live was you want really go back to
the crisper water too but it sounded
like they I didn't know why it was can't
help who we are because I was here
flippin with a tiger
mene mene bride is you Ruth at SNL
sketch this one
get with the Christopher Walken it was
leaked since this guy came in talking
about his tiger wife I don't remember
that one
no okay it was on the best of
Christopher Walken I never seen that but
it's been a long time odd that there's a
best of Christopher Walken on SNL it
just like how far he's come from being
the creepiest [ __ ] or mother
helper around sorry I'm trying not to
curse but just comes out oh well the
freakiest mother humper around and to
her that's much better
yeah cuz it gives you the visual of
humping someone's mother and then you
know there goes that god bad I don't
even know why I bother like it's just
gotten to the point like after like I
just met with the Cincinnati Children's
Hospital day and they told me that
they're like we're they're hesitant to
promote my channel just because of how
much I cursed and how much inappropriate
stuff I do talking about boo boo
losing all that but you know how it is
you know how it is
yeah I try but I mean I'm not gonna
compromise like everything about me just
to try to be family friendly like I know
what I am my my content is aimed at 15
to like 30 year-olds or something like
that so it's a big range of hello wait
I'm here I'm just working on building
stuff you're just on a story okay yeah
it was just like my content is aimed at
fifteen to thirty year old so I'm I
usually cater to that I don't try to
censor myself too much but you know
there's a certain limit to ooh what are
you doing here um this is cobblestone
I'm gonna start building another house
connected doors to build a farm on oh
cool how are we gonna keep the zom zoms
out by not being in there at night they
wouldn't call bases they're not gonna
build a first floor I'm only gonna build
a second floor the only way to get to it
from the second floor of the house that
we're in oh that's genius you're a
genius and I'm also gonna destroy the
staircase to get up to the second floor
it will help you where you worms
actually trying to get out of your way
with your headaches have you in the
bosom my bazoombas are not for you to
touch I'm sorry I think I got an implant
on my ax yeah hey ma bazooms are real
don't don't don't say they're fake
they're not all right the doctor said
they look real rubies better not
kid-friendly inside I know I know but I
mean hey come on the fact of the matter
is I don't try to go access it because
one of my funniest give me one of my
favorite comedians and the funniest guy
that I think is around is Brian Regan
and he's totally clean like you don't
need to curse to be funny but do you
mean it just happens because it's in
normal conversation ya know what I mean
but that's almost a but something I
think cursings just like the thing of
our generation man yeah me and this is
kids today they're so spoiled rotten
with their f-bombs and [ __ ] and and
a bags all that stuff man it's
unnecessary I should probably replace
some of these suppressed
supports that I knocked down because
this whole thing is gonna come crashing
down on top of my head all right
why is this not wait how do I what's
happening know what what's the matter no
it seems like there's nothing I could do
about it about it it's just placing
inside out
oh I see out it ah one more I thought I
had oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no what in the world is that noise
it's kind of creepy it's me us watching
it around oh not like that not scorching
it squirting it squirting it okay yeah
whatever I'm gonna break the up the
inside stairs so that we can get
upstairs from the interior and treks of
the outer exterior positive tear anthrax
yeah the interior en track okay know
what I'm curious about what is the
actual age of my audience you know it
got me thinking about it
can't you look at that kinda but I
wouldn't trust like analytics like
because Google tracks like everything I
can see some sort of statistics like I
know that my percentage of male the
female viewers is like 64 240 or 36 so I
have I have an abnormally high number of
female viewers thank you ladies
yeah good their ladies are not that far
off of that actually I've got a pretty
decent amount of female viewers too I
would think that because a lot of my
viewers are your viewers as well so I'm
Esther's probably uh same across the
board not saying like your entire
success is dependent on me put your
entire success depended oh don't cry
wait please cry your tears fuel my anger
or my rage
I don't want to help here's fuel my sex
drive whoa I hope I hope so
oh yes oh my guns out of ammo do bad for
you okay the stairs are clear on one
roast though hopefully there won't be a
lot I can't hear you over this puppy
sorry
you wanna stuff off my inventory is way
too full yeah it is oh yeah tell me more
about how full it is I don't want to why
not wait cuz you're creeping me out man
why
I don't know I'm getting like the
seventh degree of the lefty on from you
right now does that even mean I don't
know that is actually seventh Eon I'm
pretty sure it comes after the 6e on our
humor is so good
oh my elegant without the N on an that I
should have had there been on an yeah a
intelligent you know cuz cuz grammar
what are you even doing I'm looking at
what you're doing I don't see what
you're doing you don't understand what
I'm doing I I don't understand what
you're doing right now I'm building a
good support system in case Dom bees
break some of it down so the whole floor
doesn't collapse what I'm building like
a second structure here these are the
supports I've got a breeze them up even
higher
oh you're building a layer on top of
that okay I saw I got you do you want me
to build a platform out to there um from
the second-story we will have one yet
yeah like where I am right now cuz I'm
on the second story right she looked all
you're destroying a ladder behind you
just so you know what I'm not even
pointed at that I know it doesn't make
sense but that's what's happening
whatever fine you know what whatever I'm
gonna question it
I'm gonna go click Morse done while we
still some time with her to get back
inside soon yeah it's still only 5:30 we
got plenty of time what time does it
actually get dark honey I actually need
to pay things I think it gets dark at 10
I believe so and Tory so far gonna pick
up like one rock at a time
well isn't that just ask for you it's
sad
no it's ass but why is it that it's ass
don't question my logic I don't have
cobblestone how do I make cobblestone
for stone make cobblestone if you have
actual stones put them in the middle and
they make a stone block for stone blocks
make a cobblestone what huh I put four
in a row
Oh over there didn't like it where I put
it stupid ass yeah
over there yeah stupid mother humping
humper huh you told it
stupid humper of humper mothers yeah
yeah I'm getting it good aren't I wait
yeah you told it I told it oh yeah joy
tell us some more you sure you seem a
little hesitant on that one Wade
that's cuz my viewers are we watching
this is a what Rob your viewers are IV
way higher quality friendly do they do
they really wait but I just tried to
shift when I was moving on an edge like
as we if I was playing minecraft I'm
very very surprised with that I need
speed so many rocks yeah yeah rocks out
the that's another that's another good
old reference of a worst day that so
many babies remember that one that's not
too old though isn't it wait that's not
a reference that we came up with it that
was from that old nutrigrain commercial
do you remember that one no actually I
love you just did no no no that came
from a new tree being compared so that
was like uh this lady well he ate a
neutral gray bar or something like that
I don't remember which one we're not
sponsored by whatever company we're met
in here and he was like oh are you great
I feel so good and then he's going
around the obviously oh I feel good and
then he keeps going up good people and
y'all's up there lately
hey you're hot and I feel great let's
have some babies or something like that
let's get married her I don't remember
she's like oh you okay I want lots
Kiptyn he's like me too 500 of them ooh
and she's like yeah babies and that she
just starts going off about like a
creepy oh hey Weez Oh what Oh babies and
then she keeps going on about babies and
click go ouch uh getting kind of dark
out go inside yeah we should pardon sup
the next couple days yeah oh you're far
cuz if you build it out too far it will
just all collapse shy up I know what I'm
doing hello joy
well I'm joined I do like how the
physics kind of work in this system like
it kinda works kinda works kinda anyway
I'm gonna we're gonna spend the night
together huddled in a bed warm and cozy
in each others arms can you get inside
are you getting in from upstairs I'm
inside I'm gonna block it up with uh
wood a crap burn would rent would block
this off a little bit I actually like
how this is going because we're we're
chit-chatting but we're actually getting
stuff done if people get appreciate it
yeah we're getting close to having a
second still gonna like a farm going
it's good
any bourbon ain't too shabby I need to
get another pickaxe brain I'm not a food
what oh oh I stopped the venison yeah we
just all here how to point out what we
figured how to cook that yet no we have
a cooking pot no I gave you all the
biscuits gave you all the ayran irons in
here
Iren oh god that was sudden ha ha ha
this is tied up back in a Wade we had a
good night
productive day that was a productive day
you know now we're gonna die agree yeah
are we gonna die we better not die we've
come very far you said it yourself when
we started this we're getting to the
point where we're past what you were
doing so yeah we better not dad yeah we
tried a lot of different survival
strategies on the episodes I've recorded
on the one Molly and I have going we're
gonna start doing some of this stuff
soon yeah all that I actually made it 14
days not bad
without dying oh good for you isn't that
just fantastic but you're with me now I
know a little bit lower
oh why you gotta be like that Wade I
gotta be that day I mean he didn't kill
me twice in this series already done
action I'm like [ __ ] once in a series
episode they got strapped right cuz that
did no cover probably why they didn't
say so don't kill me because never
happened it never happened and don't
kill me while I'm mining down this Mike
alright anyway we're all that time it is
night time to pack it up if I did that
thing that in the last episode that you
guys saw it'll happen again tonight but
you if you don't know what I'm talking
about then you don't know what I'm
talking about right watch the last
episode well enough yeah good good you
didn't watch it enough so anyway yeah
we're gonna pack it in for the night
thank you guys so much for watching
whoa being the more
yep thank with you all go hey guys
what is that girl
ah my throat hurts I do another one yeah
of course huh are you good for another
yeah I'm different
okay wow there's a doggie daughter hello
get on her I think I buried unburied a
doggy that's creepy
it it was very not happy to die it do I
need food I saw this venison you want
this venison um I don't know if we can
cook it or not well I mean it still
gives us food if we don't cook it right
but not much
let me try to let me see if I can make
something here you make a campfire right
yeah we can make a campfire and then
king pot how do we do wheat I don't know
what I don't know what the second step
in there is alright we're gonna figure
this out are we so we all got a cooking
pot that'll go I guess up here maybe
okay can you make a campfire eating me
to do it uh I have a campfire thing
right here I don't know what the
materials are it's a UH
block of like tree wood and then paper
on top I think there it is we got it you
get it it's so smart you're so smart and
your thing rhymes with fart oh thank
goodness I'm smart okay
huh where do I do the campfire just set
down anywhere okay there guilt
there we go alright and the venison
where's that I have it right here in my
hands are you lack of this meat in my
hands a big ball I don't want to eat you
talk to my buzu so good mmm just dig
your face right in incoming oh oh you
like dart you lucky to meet you have to
be Josh hmm it's so good ok enough that
Oh what do we do throw the meat on the
ground for me ah cue
okay you see if I can make anything with
this all the weight Punk's around I
don't know how to make venison actually
cook I don't either
very weird hmm oh there seems to be a
structural weakness right here that's
not good
probably not that puts up enna in our
plans a banana in our plans but an ur
plans ring ring ring ring ring bananer
plans
oh boo boo doo doo in dong bling blong
bling blong banana plans I'm looking up
the recipe to click video job our
training panel is shining protectors
diamond diamond Menem a la la I don't
know how this actual song goes so I
can't even parried it whoa la la la la
la da da da doo dee ya la lu la la la la
la la la ring ring ring ring ring Nick
polite enough phone wow I hope you're
protecting me right now so I'm not even
in the game oh I'm in the same floor
just messing around I'm not I'm a debate
interview ring ring I'm doing my
Christopher Walken that's comforting
ring ring ring ring ring ring oven
banana well then you can't craft an oven
what about putting it in the oven
ahh ahh ha ha
there's no way we need 5 venison and a
clay Bowl clay bull we don't even know
any clay and a potato and of all water
to make like soup or something cliff
innocence to brew it I'm eating eyes a
doggy in here come on watch out watch
out watch out I'm moving damn it I'm
blue I'm blowing up the floor just help
me kill it I'm
I'm only hitting the floor ah damn it
die well here the floor
there we go goddamn ah God dingus Dale
oh well that was another doggy where why
are the dogs getting in in the mine how
are they getting through the mind they
were getting it I don't know it doesn't
make any damn sense I can't do anything
I'm stuck plugging up the hook where are
you I'm plugging up the holes I'm stuck
in the floor where oh there hey I
stabbed myself in the legs with an axe
ha ha
did it hurt are you aware that fell from
heaven
uh-huh uh-huh cuz your face is kind of
messed up oh why are there dogs coming
up it hello is it just cuz it's dark
down there in an empty space that they
just wanted to be okay hang on I'm gonna
I'm gonna torch it up make sure there's
no holes in the ground where they like
dug through no there's no holes it's
just like they spawned here dogs can get
through one block holes now too if
there's any structural weaknesses they
can get in it doesn't make any damn
sense are you know what I'm not gonna
dig deep I'm just gonna dig there's a
ladder aller there's power where like I
need pills I'm gonna die don't die you
fill up on food here take the venison
just eat the venison that's all we got
that's all we can do all right took two
pills I don't think I picked some food
in one of those drawers too yeah there's
some food in here like cat food and
canna pasta all right one of us might
have to run to the town to get more food
all right since you're building up the
farm oh my god